it's taking all of my strength not to
just play with it right now
so I bought my coworker a toy
is that weird I bought a toy for you
really yeah do I actually get to keep it
after this video adds up to BuzzFeed and
not I can't comment on that at this time
all right well it's hardly making sounds
first thing I do I'm gonna break it so
how you check present okay I don't know
if it's a Legos or not it's a Star Wars
something the Star Wars Perplexus Death
Star is this like in the new movie and I
don't know it yet I should have gotten
the scissor yeah you should this is
gonna be impossible to open
come on let's get the toy twist spin and
use Rebel Alliance squadron tactics to
maneuver the ball through the
challenging maze mission oh so there's a
little little x-wing in here
it seems to be on a thing and it's gonna
fly around and I need to like I guess so
almost broke my toy so it's attached by
a magnet and as you can see right here
I'm about to knock it off of its x-wing
magnet thing you see that so now what do
you do
it's like a big hamster ball really they
just like took a hamster ball and put
some Fitness well this has no no
instructions oh there's a ball in there
where in there no it's a screw that's a
screw I think we're missing a huge part
this droid I think we turn this upside
down nope that there's nothing haha so
we kind of figured it out a little bit
alright we as a starting point get it in
the top and then it kind of like spirals
down a little bit and then it goes in
there goes in there okay oh yeah
it got more fun now that we figured it
out hey this game is awesome has little
arrows to help you so now it's in that
Cup
I just have to turn it upside down
really quickly oh you did it
maybe we should redo our Oh thankings
beauty beauty it's this is a good shelf
toy this is gonna look good on your
shelf you're gonna want to play with it
it looks good next to other Star Wars
stuff but it's like a little different
fun level shut up wait let's write it
out fun level depends on the kind of
person you are honestly I had a lot of
fun once I figured it out I think it's
fun because there are it isn't
impossible but it is challenging
Perplexus perplexes like this they
perplexed us by not providing any
instructions I got a full time at that
little bit
Oh